restaurant très surfait tout en à part à
très peu de choses dans l'assiette
l'assiette la mieux garnis et celle de
l'addition un commentaire qui va coûter
plus de 11000 euros de préjudice à son
auteur un internaute dit le clarifiant
et pour cause cette critique a été
déposée sur le site internet des pages
jaunes le 11 juillet 2013 soit cinq
jours avant l'ouverture du restaurant
loiseau des ducs à dijon constat
d'huissier plainte le groupe a voulu
aller jusqu'au bout de la procédure
totalement injuste en de se prendre un
avis négatif alors que le restaurant
n'avait pas encore ouvert ses portes
nous avons travaillé sur ce projet nous
étions en train de régler les derniers
détails pour impatients d'ouvrir le
restaurant et on a un avis négatif qui
est là pour détruire et non pas pour
construire ni pour nous encourager
donc on a envie de savoir qui est caché
derrière cet avis et pourquoi et ses
propos injustes ont les doigts un
internaute un dijonnais âgé d'une
cinquantaine d'années qui n'a jamais eu
affaire au groupe loiseau et ses propos
n'ont jamais entamé la sérénité du chef
met un commentaire sur internet son
restaurant qui n'était même pas encore
ouvert en passant n'est jamais venu
manger et n'a jamais goûté ma cuisine je
trouve que c'est quand même c'est quand
même pitoyable
et puis on est honnêtes avec nous mêmes
on sait ce qu'on fait donc on n'est pas
atteint par ce genre de commentaire donc
voilà après plus de deux ans de
procédure le jugement du tribunal de
grande instance de dijon était rendu le
6 octobre dernier
dénonçant le commentaire litigieux
antérieure à l'ouverture du restaurant
et le dénigrement fautive sur des
informations non fondées
afin d'éviter ce genre de dérapages
reste maintenant législateur a créé une
loi exigeant des internautes une preuve
de leur passage dans l'établissement
sans entamer leur espace de liberté